et pour en parler nous retrouvons en
direct d'athènes temps aux états unis
ben swan journaliste d'investigation
c'est notre rubrique vu de l'extérieur
ce soir bonsoir vençoise merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur rt france alors
cet homme candidature de ce rappeur
kanye west
comment at elle été prise aux etats-unis
est-ce qu'elle a été prise au sérieux si
la tire ils sont assez intéressants
lorsque donald trump a annoncé sa
candidature en 2016 beaucoup de
personnes indices et d'absurde
comment un homme d'affaires milliardaire
et un présentateur de télé réalité
pourrait-il devenir président et non
seulement il a reçu l'investiture mais
également il a remporté la maison
blanche
et cela introduit une nouvelle idée sur
laquelle on n'a pas forcément besoin de
choisir son représentant dans les
cercles e d'hommes et de femmes
politiques de washington des gouverneurs
ou des sénateurs
mais ce qui est très intéressant avec
l'annnonce de kanye west c'est qu'il
faut regarder l'électorat qu'il vise en
2016 lorsque donald trump été contre
hillary clinton y avait beaucoup de
place pour un candidat indépendant parce
que certaines personnes apprécié d'un
troll mais beaucoup de personnes me
détester et beaucoup de personne
n'aimait pas non plus hillary clinton
et pourtant il n'y avait que deux
options pour eux annonce sa candidature
mais beaucoup de personnes considèrent
effectivement que c'est une alternative
et pour beaucoup d'autres personnes il
pourrait s'agir d'une opération
publicitaire et beaucoup de personnes
aujourd'hui disent oui il est sérieux et
il a peut-être même lâche de lâcher une
chance de gagner
alors vous vous faites vous même la
comparaison avec donald trump quand il
s'est présenté à la candidature
kanye west lui jusqu'à quel point
justement selon vous petit lob
bouleverser cette présidentielle sera
sans doute pas un candidat c'est très
fort parce que c'est politique propre ne
lui permettent pas forcément d'être un
bon candidat et nous savons pas
exactement ce qu'est l'électorat
pourrait voter pour lui il a l'argent
nécessaire il a la position et il peut
répandre son message mais nous ne
connaissons pas exactement ce message ne
savons pas son programme ne savons pas
ce qui fait de lui un meilleur candidat
kanye west s'est positionné comme un
rappeur pro trump aux états unis ce qui
est vraiment une couche très étroite de
la société il porte la casquette rouge
emblématique de donald trump sa femme
kim kardashian ouest et lui-même ce soir
anti plusieurs fois à la maison blanche
kim kardashian a travaillé avec donald
trump sur des réformes judiciaires
donc il a vraiment une position très
spécifiques et cela fait déjà plusieurs
années quatre cinq voire six ans qu'il
dit vouloir concourir en 2020 donc c'est
intéressant qu'il ait choisi cette année
et certaines personnes considéraient
qu'il attendrait 2024 lorsque donald
trump ne serait plus en lice il y aura
des gens qui n'aiment pas de m il y aura
des gens qui n'en ont pas non plus le
candidat démocrate joe dalton
est-ce que kanye west représentera une
alternative viable pour ces personnes ou
un autre candidat sans doute plus
légitime
apparaîtra-t-il alors il ya quand même
la question vous dites voilà c'est
quelque chose qui était pensé depuis
longtemps mais il ya quand même la
question du timing il s'y prend plutôt
tard gagné ouest pour annoncer cette
candidature déjà il est hors délai
peut-être dans certains états et puis on
ne sait pas s'il va faire cavalier seul
ou s'il va essayer de faire un petit
parti ça ne s'improvise pas tout ça
tout à fait il serait forcé de concours
et en tant que candidats indépendants
mais cela ne serait pas un problème
parce qu'il suffirait d'être inscrit sur
le scrutin dans les états les plus
importants
il va y avoir une rhétorique au tour de
kanye west disant qu'il pourrait égaler
la situation ils votent pour canohès
plutôt que joe biden alors pour les
démocrates c'est un vote pour donald
trump et si on vote pour kanye west au
livre de donald trump pour les
républicains c'est un vote pour joe
biden donc on dira que voter pour
cagnois c'est voter pour l'autre
candidat celui qu'on aime pas donkey la
rhétorique va être très très controversé
mais c'est une bonne chose en quelque
sorte parce que cela permet d'éviter des
critiques du fait du manque de temps
mais je pense que kanye west se lance
dans une tempête ce pour laquelle il
n'est pas prêt car il ya vraiment
beaucoup de critiques beaucoup de
polémiques autour des candidats et je
pense que kanye west va toutefois pas
souffrir de cela alors c'est vrai aussi
qu'il sort un album kanye west du coup
toutes les chaînes on parle il n'y a pas
vraiment de programme en tout cas vous
aviez l'air de dire qu'on ne sait pas
vraiment ce qu'ils proposent ce que
voilà on peut vraiment prendre
clairement cette candidature au sérieux
c'est pas tout simplement un coup pub de
la part du rappeur qui connaît très bien
les réseaux de communication en
attestent évidemment sa femme la reine
des réseaux sociaux n'est ce pas chez
elle est absolument la reine des réseaux
sociaux
est-ce que kanye west et sérieux je le
pense il en parle depuis longtemps la
question est la suivante est ce que
kanye west qui est une personne très
intéressante
quel que soit votre opinion sur sa
politique ou sa musique at il planifié
la situation at il déjà construit un
programme une chose certaine il réussira
très bien apporter le
sage effectivement lui et sa femme sont
très doués pour cela met la question et
peuvent-ils développer une stratégie
cohérente pour le développement et le
gouvernement
au cours de leur mandat à si c'est le
cas alors effectivement et pourrait
acquérir un certain élan parce que des
gens vont se tourner vers lui en ce 10
ans est un candidat sérieux
mais s'il se contente de dire je veux
être candidat à voter pour moi parce que
jeune fille je ne suis ni donald trump
ni joe biden alors il n'a aucune chance
merci beaucoup antoine d'avoir été avec
nous en direct sur arte france pour vu
de l'extérieur